Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we are still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
Introducing
your infinite closet.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Wow!
Narrator:
...by working smart...
‐Help us teach America...
‐Mmm.
Both:
...a new way to waffle.
This is sick.
Narrator:
...by thinking big...
Sharks,
you guys ready to cool off?
Together: Yeah.
Narrator:
...and chasing their dreams.
There is a tenacity
that I have,
and I am going to break through
any obstacle ever.
Your revenue is what?
$7,000.
O'Leary: Oh!
This is
a very special business.
Are you crazy?!
I don't want to have to put you
in time‐out.
You lied to us.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a European twist
to a popular breakfast treat.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Bryan Lewis.
And I'm Caleb Lewis.
And together, we are...
Press Waffle Co.
We're a fully family‐owned
business based in Dallas, Texas.
‐What?!
‐We specialize
in authentic
Belgian waffle creations.
We are here today
seeking $200,000
in exchange for 8% equity
in our company.
Now, Sharks, when I say waffle,
what do you think of?
One of those thin, frozen,
lifeless breakfast substitutes?
Sorry, friends, but this?
This ain't no waffle.
Now let me take you
on a journey
to a region of Belgium
untouched by the sticky
fingers of American cuisine.
We begin with a dense,
buttery, brioche‐style dough
that takes 24 hours
to rise.
‐Ohh.
‐Oh.
After that, we sprinkle in
some beautiful
Belgian pearl sugar.
‐Mmm.
‐This is sugar that melts down
in the iron to form
a golden caramel crust
around a chewy,
fluffy waffle center...
‐Oh, preach it, Bryan.
‐...giving you the perfect bite.
Now, that is a waffle.
‐We want some.
‐Oh...my...goodness.
I'm getting all hot
just thinking about it!
Am I right, Barbara?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, Barbara.
Bryan:
And if that wasn't enough,
you can fully customize
your waffle
from our selection
of over 16 different toppings.
Or if you're feeling
really crazy,
you can go with one
of our savory selections,
like our best‐selling
chicken and waffles
or our Monte Cristo
waffle sandwich.
Wow.
Sharks, we have
something special,
and we want to get
these waffles into as many hands
as possible
all across America.
So join our team
of waffle enthusiasts
and help us teach America...
Both:
...a new way to waffle.
Who's hungry?
‐Waffle on, baby. Let's go.
‐Oh.
‐You've got our attention now.
‐Bring them on, bring them on.
Good, good. Caleb's gonna
make it for you right here.
I'm gonna finish it up
for you.
So, what he's gonna be
making for you today
is called The House.
It's our
number‐one‐selling waffle.
What it's gonna be is
some fresh‐cut strawberries,
our house‐made
whipped cream...
Corcoran: Mmm.
...a little bit
of cookie butter,
a little bit of Nutella.
‐I hate you guys already.
‐Ah.
Greiner: Oh, my God.
[ Laughing ] Ohh.
‐There you go, Robert.
‐We'll give Lori one.
Yeah, there goes
my no‐carb diet.
Yeah.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Oh!
‐Sir.
‐Today is a good day. Yeah.
‐It is a good day. Yes, sir.
‐Yes.
Oh, my God.
That's good.
‐Thank you.
‐These are dough‐based waffles,
so they are gonna be denser.
‐Oh, my God.
‐They've got more texture.
‐My God.
‐So good.
‐How many calories in The House?
So, we have not done
nutritional testing, and...
Too many.
‐No!
‐...you know, we don't ‐‐
We don't ‐‐
‐Na, na, na, na, na, na!
Don't tell me! Don't tell me!
We ‐‐ We don't want to
because the thing is,
is we are
an indulgent product.
‐Mmm.
‐We are not aiming ‐‐ Like...
This is sick.
It's sick in a good way.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
Herjavec: Can we find out
how much it is?
What do you charge
for it?
So, The House is $8.
Who came up with the idea?
What was the "a‐ha!" moment?
Basically,
a couple years ago,
my wife and I were
traveling through Europe.
I sit down
at this little café,
and I say,
"Can I get a waffle?"
And I took a bite into it,
and I was like,
"Ho‐ly crap."
[ Imitates explosion ]
I was like, "I've never had
anything like this before."
When we came back, I couldn't
find these waffles anywhere,
so just as a hobby, I started
making them on my own.
How much do you make
per square foot,
or what is the total size
of the store?
We're over
$5,000 per square foot.
Very good, gentlemen.
‐We're, uh ‐‐
‐Wow.
‐Uh‐huh.
‐How many locations?
How many loc‐‐ one location?
Greiner: And are you in a mall,
or are you a stand‐still?
So, it's the first
European‐style food hall
in North Texas.
A food hall is basically like
your upscale food court.
So what you're talking about
is local chefs,
artisan creators,
and food vendors.
It's a destination.
It's not ‐‐ Yeah.
What's the revenue on that
location gonna be this year?
$900,000.
We have really good margins.
We're operating at about
a 14% profit margin.
So ‐‐ But where else
is next, then?
There's not a lot of those
types of destinations.
‐There are.
‐So, there are.
‐It is all ‐‐ It's a huge trend.
‐The food hall segment, guys,
is exploding!
Corcoran: It's growing
like gangbusters.
It's crazy.
O'Leary: The model is,
they're getting a royalty
off your sales, right?
Cuban: 8%?
25.5%
right where we are now.
‐Whoa!
‐What?!
‐Yeah, wait. Repeat that.
‐Whoa!
‐And we still have 14% ‐‐
‐Repeat that.
‐Hang on, hang on, hang on.
‐Right now ‐‐
‐Repeat that.
‐Right now, we are paying 25.5%
off of
our top‐line revenues,
and we are
still generating a 14% profit.
‐Off gross revenue?
‐Okay, so, what other ‐‐
‐And that is our rent.
‐Gross.
But what are
the circumstances ‐‐
Caleb: That's our rent
and utilities.
And if I understand it
correctly ‐‐
Let's say you sell nothing
for the month.
Would your rent be zero?
Yes.
But how do you know that you'll
be able to take this concept
and get in at the same rent
in all these other locations?
So, first of all,
we already have
seven other food halls
in place,
signed L. O. I. s or leases.
‐All in Texas?
‐As franchises or yours?
As company‐owned stores.
25.5%
is what we're paying now.
We're not gonna pay
more than 20% anywhere,
and most of them are 15%.
What ‐‐ Bryan,
what does it cost you
to build out
a new location?
About $115,000 to $150,000.
‐That's very, very cheap.
‐That's it?
The other locations,
do you have a similar deal,
that if you don't sell
for a month...
Yes.
Yeah.
...the rent is zero?
Yes, sir.
There are ‐‐ There are ‐‐
That's why you can open up
so many locations.
Exactly.
Okay, guys,
I like what you're doing.
Right?
But 8% isn't enough.
I can help you.
Obviously in Dallas,
I can ‐‐ I can help a lot.
Yes, sir.
And ‐‐ And ‐‐ And help
with the financing, as well.
‐Okay.
‐So, what I'll offer you
is $350,000
for 20% of the company.
That is an awesome offer,
and we really appreciate it.
That is ‐‐ That is
an incredible offer.
Seriously.
Out ‐‐ Out of re‐‐
I‐I ‐‐ We would love to be able
to hear the other Sharks out.
Corcoran:
I'd like to give you an offer.
As I'm listening to your
numbers, they're identical,
every inch of it,
to Cousins Maine Lobster, okay?
They have 35 locations,
and sales right now
are $45 million.
That's a little bit better
than $1 million a store.
They have learned
'cause they grew very quickly,
but they did it so smartly,
just like you.
They're rock solid,
and they could have hired
and/or opened
maybe 500% more trucks,
but they're smart enough to know
it's all in the partnership.
So, I'm gonna give you
a choice.
I'll give you $200,000
for 15%.
Okay.
Or I'll give you $400,000
for 30%.
♪♪
O'Leary: I don't think
you should give up
1/3 of your company.
I'd structure
a different way.
I'd do the $200,000 for debt,
straight loan.
You can afford to pay it back.
It's not difficult.
And I'll be there
lending you for every opening,
and I'll do it
for 3% equity.
The interest rate
would be 7% to 11%,
depending on the amount
of risk of each location.
That's actually
a very good offer.
It's a rip‐off.
No, it isn't.
‐Yes, it is.
‐No, it's not.
You're giving up
1/3 of your company?
‐He's not taking more than 3%.
‐That's crazy.
Greiner: I think
that's an excellent offer.
Well, thank you, Lori.
He's only taking ‐‐
No, I'm sorry, Barb,
but that's just ‐‐
No problem. Thank you, Lori.
I'm just being honest.
It's 3%,
is all he's taking.
So I'm sitting here thinking,
"How can I top that?"
I‐I don't think I can.
So I will politely go out.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you, Lori.
We appreciate it.
You know, when you start
a new business,
sometimes it works, sometimes
you plod along for years.
Mm‐hmm.
And sometimes
you just go, "A‐ha!"
And I think
you're onto something.
I like the idea to open up
all six locations.
Step back, reassess.
I'll give you the $600,000
for all six locations.
I'm just trying to figure out
what amount of equity
are you gonna give me
for that.
And I ‐‐ And by the way...
Make us an offer.
...you guys are the guys.
Thank you, sir.
I want to bet on you.
What is your offer?
I'm gonna give them $600,000.
‐I don't know what equity to ‐‐
‐For what?
‐For zero equity?
‐Make me an offer.
What amount of equity are
you gonna give me for that?
‐I‐I think ‐‐ I think ‐‐
‐Counter at zero equity.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Caleb and Bryan
have three offers on the table
for their Belgian waffle
business, Press Waffle,
but Robert wants to know
how much equity
they are willing to offer
if he gives them
three times the money
they are seeking.
For $600,000,
we would have
to give away an amount
of our company
that we wouldn't
be comfortable doing.
That we're not comfortable
doing.
‐Yeah.
‐I appreciate the offer,
and you're right ‐‐
$600,000 is what we need
to open those stores,
but realistically,
I know you're not gonna ‐‐
We ‐‐ We won't give up
more than 20% of the company.
That's why debt works!
What about this?
What about $400,000
for 20%?
That's a very good offer.
That's a great offer.
Mm‐hmm.
I happen to think
I'm worth more.
I hate to say it.
I'm not a braggadocio type,
but I really do.
He doesn't have
the infrastructure
for building
food businesses.
I own 16 of them.
‐Bryan, she's right ‐‐ I don't.
‐A big difference.
But you know what? I think
we're gonna figure it out.
It's gonna cost him more
to figure it out with you.
I'm all about figuring
it out, Robert.
Come on.
We're gonna figure it out.
To be ‐‐ To be totally honest ‐‐
To be totally honest with you,
we're here for somebody
who has been there before.
Hey, guys, you know what?
I‐I bought a towel that
I really didn't understand.
The company's
called Sand Cloud.
Mm‐hmm.
We figured it out.
We're doing $17 million
this year.
The only other reason that I'm
hesitant about your offer is,
I think our vision lines up
more along Kevin's route
than yours.
‐Yes. Yes.
‐Really?
Caleb: We're not ‐‐
Not ‐‐ not ‐‐ not ‐‐
Why give up all that equity?
Not with that deal, but just
being as big as we possibly can.
Mm‐hmm.
We want this to be a company
that still exists in five years.
O'Leary:
Don't give up all your equity.
You need a proven model.
Barbara, would you come down
on your equity?
To how much?
Could we do $300,000
for 15%?
Uh...
We have a deal right now.
What's bothering you
about that ‐‐
the amount of money
or the percentage?
The percentage is what we're
trying to protect, honestly.
All right.
The value of the company,
as well.
$250,000 for 15%.
That's halfway.
This waffle is talking to me
and saying, "Don't give up 15%."
It's a great deal.
Don't do it, kids.
It's a fair deal.
Don't do it.
Um...
I'm trying to do
mental math.
Yeah, so am I.
Don't do it!
We ‐‐ That ‐‐ That puts us
at like $1.6 million?
So, over the next 12 months,
we plan to do
$3.5 million in sales,
and of that, we plan
to net about $500,000.
I get it.
We put a simple
five times valuation on that.
That's how we got
to $2.5 million.
That's without your help.
$300,000 for 15%.
That makes it
a $2 million valuation.
Are you comfortable
with that?
Yes, I am.
Then we're comfortable
with that.
Okay.
‐Thank you.
‐All right, we have a deal.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐[ Groans ]
‐I hope I did the right thing.
I think you did
the right thing.
You did the right thing.
‐I did the right thing
with you guys, for sure.
Thank you all.
Thank you so much, everyone!
Congrats, guys.
For what you paid,
you also get this waffle,
'cause you're
gonna need it.
Thank you very much.
[ Laughs ]
Let's go, baby!
Whoo!
Two years ago,
we didn't know anything
about the food industry,
and...
And we just got a deal, valuing
our company at $2 million
from Barbara Corcoran.
That's the American dream.
The partner we wanted.
That is the American dream.
That's incredible.
♪♪
Narrator:
In season 9, Joshua Esnard
made a deal with Daymond John
for his hair‐grooming accessory,
The Cut Buddy.
I'm gonna ride with you.
Let's see how Cut Buddy
is doing now.
Esnard: When I launched in 2016,
The Cut Buddy went viral,
but then we got knocked off
over 2,000 times.
When I pitched to the Sharks,
we had only done $115,000
in sales in 2017.
Making a deal with Daymond
changed everything.
Welcome to New York City.
When you're knocked off
that many times,
the only way to win the game
is to be the first to retail.
Daymond has helped
make that happen.
We finalized a deal
with Andis Clippers,
one of the oldest distributors
of hair‐grooming tools
in America.
Nothing better
than a free check.
Nothing ‐‐ Nothing...
Royalties.
Licensing is important
because, like, getting people
to do all the hard work
and sending you a royalty check.
And then you don't have anybody
who owns part of your company.
You get it all back
when it's all over.
Andis introduced The Cut Buddy
as a bonus product
in their grooming kits,
but it did so well
that now it's going to be
a stand‐alone product.
Cut Buddy's
already in 10,000 stores
and one of the top sellers
on Amazon.
In under a year, he's done
over $800,000 in sales.
Congratulations.
Oh, my goodness.
We've made it
to the big time.
So exciting!
Esnard:
My wife used to nudge me
and tell me that I never finish
what I start,
and now I'm finishing
what I started.
My product's on shelves
all across the nation.
I think I'm really living
the American dream now.
As an immigrant from a
developing country, Saint Lucia,
not having the opportunity
and just seeing your product
looking at you,
I love Daymond for that,
and thank you, "Shark Tank."
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a business
that aims to maximize
the life of your clothing.
♪♪
They mean business.
[ Chuckles ]
Hello.
My name is Janet Wu.
And
I'm Erin Wold‐Fettner.
We are from San Francisco,
California,
and our company
is SilkRoll.
At SilkRoll, making
secondhand fashion mainstream
is our first priority.
There are tons of fashion
in great shape
that are just sitting
in our closets.
For example,
the average Millennial
wears an item
just three times.
So why do they all just end up
sitting in our closets?
That's because when you try
to consign or resell them,
you get screwed.
With traditional consignment ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
What are
you looking at me for?
With traditional consignment
and resell services,
you typically get $10
for your $100 dress.
And who thinks
that's fair?
Introducing
your infinite closet.
SilkRoll.
SilkRoll is an exchange
that pays you points
for those unused clothes
and handbags in your closet.
We give you
an equivalent amount of points
to what you
initially paid,
and then you use
those points
to shop for items of
the same value on our site.
Trading clothes on SilkRoll
is easy.
You get a prepaid trading kit
in the mail,
you stuff it
with clothes you don't use,
and drop it in the mail.
Once your clothes
enters our system,
you earn points
and browse our site
to trade with other members
of our community.
You get fresh looks
delivered to your door
without paying a dime.
Oh, yeah! Money.
We are seeking $250,000
in exchange
for 3% equity.
‐Oy.
‐3%
‐What?!
‐3%!
‐Why does everybody...
‐Ah!
Both: So...
who wants to try us on
for size?
‐Oh, my.
‐Do women lie
about what they paid for the
dress that they just sent you?
We have a ‐‐ a database
where we valuate all the items
that they send us.
Initially,
we look at the brands,
the condition, the style.
Over time,
the valuation database
actually becomes
dynamic and smart.
We'll have algorithms
that look at the supply
and demand dynamics,
and then the dresses,
or the products ‐‐
So you're saying
you overcomplicate
a simple business.
‐Actually not.
‐So, this is actually great.
So, we look at Lori's dress,
and we say, "All right,
that brand
and dresses from that brand
retail at ‐‐
in this price range."
I put together 10 items.
I ship them to you.
If it comes in damaged or ripped
or stained, what happens?
‐Do you send it back?
‐We don't.
If there's
a really high‐luxury brand
that has any signs
of wear and tear...
Like small ‐‐ Yeah.
...we will note that
on the site and still list it.
But what if it's cheap and
stained and you receive it?
What do you do
with the item then?
So, about 25% of the items
that we receive,
we do not keep, and we give
those products to charity.
O'Leary: What about the points?
Do I get my points?
You do not earn points
for items that we don't keep.
In fact, we deduct
a small amount of points
because you didn't do
your homework...
Oh.
...to send us
the accurate products.
‐So you punish me?
‐That's good. Good for you.
‐You punish me.
‐Janet, how do you make money?
Great question!
All right, so, let's say
you're an average customer,
and you spend $700 worth
of points on four items,
and you pay $45.
I still don't understand
how you make money.
Lori sent her the dress,
you gave her 200...
points for it.
Points, yeah.
Kevin now buys that dress...
Yeah.
...for 200 points.
Yep.
How did you make money
on that transaction?
So, Kevin paid
a 5% transaction fee to spend ‐‐
Do I know that?
Do I know it?
Yes, you knew ‐‐ you knew...
Yep. You know it at checkout.
Greiner:
Oh, so, anybody that buys.
Okay, so that's
the heart of this.
You keep ‐‐
You keep 5% either way.
‐So it's a commission you get.
‐Yep.
‐This is ‐‐
‐What's the dollar amount
on the 200 points
that Kevin spent?
What's 5%?
That's $10.
For that $200 dress.
So each point is a dollar?
Yeah, when you're trading.
You're making 5%.
No. We make 68% margins
on every order.
[ Screams ]
When do you make money?
‐When Lori ‐‐
‐So ‐‐
The moment that Lori
spends any of her points.
Yeah.
Let's say I earn 500 points,
but I want a $600 dress.
Got it.
I have to buy 100 points.
And I'm like,
"Oh, I'm 100 points short."
Then they go and buy
those points to make it up.
So, right now,
we sell points in bundles.
50 cents a point, and then
it goes to 33 cents a point,
and then 25 cents a point.
So we sold 100 points,
made $50.
Then we make another 5%
on 600 points.
Now, here's
the big question...
$250,000 for 3% ‐‐
That's
an $8.3 million valuation.
Now, I am
the fashionista here.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Not.
I'm the one that looks
spectacular all the time.
Awesome.
Cuban: Says the man who wears
the exact same suit.
He wears the same clothes
every single day.
‐No, that's ‐‐
‐Every day.
‐I am the fashionista Shark.
‐He has 30 of the same suit.
‐You have to explain ‐‐
‐All joking aside,
you're looking for 3%.
‐Uh‐huh.
‐$250,000 for 3%.
‐Okay.
This must be
a massive business.
‐It ‐‐ It is. Okay.
‐Okay.
Let's get those numbers out,
ladies.
Wold‐Fettner: Yes.
‐Yeah.
‐Yes, yes.
Wu: Okay, so, if you guys
are trying to value us
as a traditional business...
‐Ohh! Here we go.
‐Hold on.
This is
a very special business.
[ Laughter ]
It is. Okay?
Okay, okay.
Why won't you give us
the numbers?
Yeah, so,
we launched last year.
Okay.
And we've already traded
through the platform
$2.3 million worth of product
in points.
That means nothing.
‐Yeah, that ‐‐ Okay.
‐Yeah, but you get 5% of that.
‐Yeah.
‐Keep going.
‐You get 5% of the number?
‐Your revenue is what?
So, our revenue was $35,000.
‐Are you ‐‐
‐Oh.
That is
a very special business.
Are you out of your mind?
That is
a very special business.
Like, you're trying to tell me
you're worth $8.3 million?
‐Wait.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, my God.
‐You know I have no choice
but to eviscerate you!
‐Are you serious?
Are you crazy?!
This business
is not a lifestyle business.
We're building
a marketplace
that's got a network effect.
In fact, it expands over time.
But there is
no network effect.
There is no network effect.
Actually, we do.
So, we're building
style‐matching algorithms
through machine learning.
On average, a customer
trades products with us ‐‐
But ‐‐ But that's just
a personalization.
That's not
a network effect.
Such bad things
are gonna happen here today.
This is a business, I think,
that has two weak points.
I think your 5% commission
is not large enough
to really make much money
with this.
Secondly, I don't like
the name at all.
‐Yeah, I agree.
‐I don't think it has anything
to do
with what the business is.
That's a good point.
And so for
those two weak spots ‐‐
and they're
important weak spots ‐‐
first impression and
how do you generate revenue,
I'm out.
Cuban: Guys, look, I lived
off of consignment clothes.
My first two suits when
I started MicroSolutions,
my first company,
when I was 23,
were two for $99.
So I get it, right?
I think the marketplace idea
is great.
But what I see that I think
is ‐‐ is a red flag is,
you talk
a lot of buzzwords ‐‐
machine learning,
network effect,
you know, using A.I.
to do all these things
that are
very Silicon Valley,
and I'm sure
help you raise money.
You get away
from the simplicity
of what your business
should be.
It should be
just about getting users.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
You...
probably couldn't have done
a more confusing presentation.
I heard multiple streams of
revenue that you're trying.
You're ‐‐ You're doing it on
points, you have a percentage,
when I buy points,
I get a perc‐‐
Like, I would have
rather you come out and say,
"Look, we haven't figured out
the revenue model,
but, man,
we are growing our exchange."
‐Mm.
‐But I‐I couldn't follow it.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪
After 10 years
of "Shark Tank,"
and seeing all kinds
of deals,
one of the things
that entrepreneurs ‐‐
and you're two
intelligent women ‐‐
The biggest mistake
they make is,
they come here,
stand where you are,
and give me
ridiculous valuations.
Just plain stupid.
$35,000 in revenue.
You want a valuation
of over $8 million.
It's just ridiculous.
There's nothing to do here.
I am out.
This ‐‐ The business could be a
$100‐billion‐valuation business.
This is a huge profit.
You don't think anybody else
sits on that carpet
and says that?
Greiner:
You know, listen.
Everything that was said up
here, learning lessons, right?
‐Yeah.
‐You have way too big an ask.
This ‐‐ This is a ‐‐ This...
Way too big an ask
for a Shark to get excited
about, so I'm sorry.
We're building
a future here.
I'm out.
And the future
of this business ‐‐
Not with any Shark here,
you are.
‐See you later.
‐Uh!
‐Sorry, guys.
‐Yeah.
‐We wish you the best.
I must say, I'm gonna invoice
both of you for my time today.
You actually have
to leave now.
Okay.
‐Thank you.
[ Sighs ]
Wow.
It's ‐‐ It [Groans]
Corcoran: Mm.
Wold‐Fettner: We weren't able
to effectively communicate
our numbers to the Sharks.
There was a lot of, like, all
kinds of questions coming at us,
and, you know, when we're
trying to answer this person,
that person, then the ‐‐
the story, the wor‐‐
the flow was jumbled.
And so confusing.
So that's why
they didn't get it. Right?
"Do I do this first or that?
Oh, what? Buy points for ‐‐"
We hope ‐‐
But I hope America gets it.
How much do you hate
when somebody comes in,
starts using "machine
learning," "A. I."?
‐Oh, God.
‐A.I. Just, yeah.
‐I mean, I‐I...
‐Neural networks.
And they're selling dresses
with stains on them.
And their network.
No, the best part was...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is an affordable way
to enjoy a luxury.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Tommy Prestella.
And I'm an Air Force pilot
from San Dimas, California.
I'm here today seeking $100,000
for 25% of my company.
Now, Sharks, I love summer days
as much as the next guy.
What's not to love, right?
I mean, backyard barbecues,
evening baseball games ‐‐
I love it all.
But, Sharks,
there's one thing about summer
that I just really don't like.
Uh‐oh.
It's freaking hot!
And if you've been stationed
in the Deep South,
like I have
for the last 12 years,
or deployed overseas to Iraq,
Afghanistan, Africa,
you know that those places
get crazy hot.
I got sick and tired
of sweating through my clothes
every time I stepped outside
and just always
being uncomfortable.
Mm.
So I fused together
a creative way
to stay cool
and beat the summer heat.
Sharks, you guys
ready to cool off?
Together: Yeah.
‐Boo‐yah!
‐Come on, Tommy!
Prestella: Introducing the one
and only Pick‐up Pool.
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, as you can see,
the Pick‐up Pool is the ultimate
truck‐bed swimming pool.
This patented pool liner
instantly transforms
the bed of your pickup truck
into an aboveground pool.
Simply pull the corners
of the Pick‐up Pool
over the corners
of your truck bed, add water,
and, bam,
you're ready for a pool party.
‐Wow.
‐When you're done,
there's a drain at the back.
You can drain the water
without lowering your tailgate.
I like it.
Now, Sharks, the Pick‐up Pool
is a brand‐new product
in an untapped market.
So what do you say?
Who wants to go for a swim
and make a deal
with Pick‐up Pool?
How did
you come up with this?
My inspiration
was my daughter.
‐Aww!
Prestella: Way back when,
when I got the idea for this,
we were living in Arkansas.
It's 2014.
Crazy hot summer.
And my daughter says,
"Daddy, I want to go swimming,"
and I'm like ‐‐ I'm heartbroken,
and she's heartbroken
because I don't have
a swimming pool.
So I was like, "Well..."
Aww.
I was like,
"Let's see what I can do."
I go in the garage.
I'd seen it done before.
I was, "We'll get a tarp."
I got some bungee cords.
I make this thing in the back of
my truck, and it's ‐‐ It worked,
but it was an ugly mess.
And what if it leaks?
These do not leak.
These are
a very thick, durable material.
Lifetime guarantee on them.
It's the same stuff
aboveground pool liners are
that last 30 years.
‐Wow.
‐Good for you, Tommy.
First of all,
thank you for your service.
Hey, it's my pleasure.
Thank you.
What's the patent for?
So, the patent is,
it's the adaptable
watertight barrier.
I'm the only person
who can make the bed
of the pickup truck
watertight.
So, where are
you selling these now?
‐So, I sell them mainly online.
‐How much do you sell them for?
Prestella:
So, they cost me $110 and $117
to make for the two sizes,
and then I sell them
through my website
for $200 and $210,
respectively.
How much have you sold?
Year to date ‐‐ $7,060.
Killing it, huh?
[ Laughs ]
Killing it.
[ Laughter ]
Lifetime sales ‐‐ $12,000.
But there's a story there.
What's the story?
I got the idea 2014,
did a proof of concept in 2015,
bought 20 pools.
Immediately,
I got the website up,
I'm getting hits on the website,
and I'm like,
"People really like this."
I sell those 20.
I go back to get more.
Manufacturer retired.
That sucks.
So now I'm back to square one
with nobody to make the pools.
So 2016's pretty much gone
me looking for a manufacturer.
2017, deployed to an undisclosed
location in Africa.
But I had to, obviously, hit
the brakes on Pick‐up Pools
'cause I was a one‐man show
at the time.
So I brought my sister on.
Very responsible.
Love my sister to death.
She found me the manufacturer
who makes this.
Wow. Nice.
She ‐‐ She's a part owner.
She's got a percentage
of the company, as well.
Good.
So...
‐That's not her in there, right?
‐No.
So, can I talk about her?
That's my beautiful wife
of 12 years right there.
Together: Aww!
Really?
‐So...
‐Whoo!
Prestella: So, supporting me
relentlessly ‐‐
Well, who's the guy
she's fooling around with?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She's in a hot tub
with some other guy!
Yeah. That's my best friend
from college.
‐Ohh!
‐That's who that is, huh?
[ Laughter ]
So, what are
you gonna do going forward?
What's the plan?
So, the reason
I'm asking for money today,
I want to re‐juice my website
and figure out how to drive
traffic to my website.
My website right now, it ‐‐
it looks nice, but I made it.
I'm not a Web developer.
I'm really proud of myself
I made a website.
I'm like, "Wow."
I want to have a professional
redo my website.
You're basically saying
you're gonna spend the money
to market the product.
The product's in the market.
It's good quality.
$12,000 lifetime sales
since the beginning
is really abysmal.
Okay.
Well, look at it this way,
Kevin.
The guy gets deployed
to an unknown,
to‐be‐unnamed place
in Africa.
I get it,
but ‐‐ but the product's ‐‐
I got this. Thank you, Mark.
I got this one.
But, I mean, if the only way
it can sell is you, Tommy,
are, like,
barking at the Internet,
I just don't know
if people care.
You've sold
$12,000 worth of it.
Like, it's total nothing.
That's an 800% increase
from last year, Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
True story.
‐Yeah, Tommy!
‐Good for you.
‐Good.
What do your platoon buddies
think of it?
‐Ohh.
‐Oh, they love it.
I've actually ‐‐
I've brought it
to an undisclosed location
in the Middle East.
Tommy, who would work
your business?
You're still
full‐time military?
I‐I am married to the military
for the next eight years,
so there's no pulling the wool
over your guys' eyes here.
And so, I ‐‐ That's ‐‐
Yeah, but then
back to the question
of who would work
your business.
‐His sister.
‐My sister
is the other part of me.
Where is she based?
She's here
in Southern California.
Can you get the price ‐‐
the cost down lower?
Thank you for asking that.
You're welcome.
Yeah.
I'm proud to say
they're 100% made in America.
Good.
It's part of the reason
why it's so expensive.
I want to make it for $25
and sell it for $60.
Right.
That's where I'm trying
to get with this.
I think there's room
to get that done a lot cheaper.
Listen, I think
you did a good job of name.
[ Sighs ]
Pick‐up Pools.
Intuitive.
You got a patent.
Great job.
My problem here is, I have
no idea of the market.
I believe you ‐‐ It would
work and keep people cool,
but I have no idea
of the market research.
Yeah, no.
Under‐‐ Understandable.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
Tommy, you're ‐‐
you're a great guy.
I really admire the ‐‐
the effort you've put into it.
I‐I just don't know
if there's a business.
You haven't sold
very much.
You've got to find a way
to get from 20 or 30
to hundreds.
Well, think of the value you're
gonna add when you join me, Rob.
And then, all of a sudden,
we have all those resources.
You're a great sales guy.
Right?
I'm not jumping in the pool
with you. I'm out.
♪♪
This thing,
you fill up with water,
and then, the next hour,
you got to drive somewhere ‐‐
Forget it.
No, don't ‐‐ don't ‐‐
don't drive with it.
Look, the product
is telling you,
"Tommy, I don't think so."
I'm out
from an undisclosed location.
[ Laughter ]
Copy that.
I'm gonna make you an offer,
'cause I think it's ‐‐
Whoa!
I think ‐‐
I love this product.
‐Didn't see that coming.
‐I love it, too!
But I have
a few contingencies.
Your sister
has to be committed to it.
She is.
It has to have a salesman.
And I really have
to like your sister.
Oh, you're gonna love her.
You have to bring the price
down to under 100 bucks.
I absolutely think we can.
I believe you.
With those contingencies,
I'll give you the $100,000
for 25%.
Okay.
Tommy, is there anybody
that has a formal product
that could be ‐‐
No, sir.
No, I am the only person
that ‐‐ that sells this.
And you think your patent
protects you
from anybody else doing it?
Absolutely.
It's "watertight."
I don't think so. Anybody
can get a piece of plastic
and throw it
in the back of a truck.
I'll offer you $100,000
for 33%,
no contingencies,
recognizing that you're
gonna be off quite a bit.
We'll just work together
to get the price down.
I'll also get this to my guys
at Tower Paddle Board.
They can get out there
and start promoting.
That's it, Tommy.
Let's rock 'n' roll.
What do you think?
Barbara, I love watching you
on the show,
and I thank you for that...
Tommy, you have two offers.
I can't believe it!
Thank you
for that amazing deal...
Corcoran: Wait.
Wait. Just a minute.
The last time somebody
told me he loved me,
he left me
and married my sister.
[ Laughter ]
I would never do that.
I would never do that to you.
Mark, I‐I appreciate...
Don't negotiate.
...that you understand
where I'm coming from.
Yeah, don't negotiate.
Let's do a deal.
‐You got it.
‐Ohh!
‐Oh!
Doggone! Unh!
Herjavec: Barbara,
he's marrying your sister!
I guess he is.
And thanks for what you do.
I have no idea
if the business is gonna work,
but it was a great pitch.
‐It'll work.
‐Hey, pleasure to meet you guys.
‐You're a great guy.
‐Thank you very much. Thank you.
‐Thank you for your service.
‐Shock‐a‐roo.
‐Thanks, Tommy.
Wow!
Prestella: Mark's deal
was not necessarily sweeter
in terms of money, but he
understands what my work life
is like, and he's ‐‐ he's
willing to flex on that.
So that's why I ended up
going with Mark.
♪♪
Hi.
My name's Mikaila Ulmer.
And I'm the founder and C. E. O.
of Me & the Bees Lemonade,
formerly BeeSweet.
Congratulations
on 10 seasons of "Shark Tank."
Before I was on "Shark Tank,"
I was in only one Whole Foods
in Austin, Texas,
but now I'm in
over 650 natural grocery stores
across the United States.
Thank you, Mr. John,
for being an amazing partner
and the best Shark ever,
and congratulations
on 10 seasons.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an accessory
to help kids
eat healthier snacks.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
Whoo.
Corcoran: Hi.
♪♪
Ladies and gentlemen...
and Kevin...
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Wow.
...my name is Lisa D'Amato...
That's not a good way
to suck up, Lisa.
I think we'll have fun.
Okay.
My name is Lisa D'Amato, and I'm
from Los Angeles, California.
These are my boys,
Daxel and Venice.
I'm seeking $350,000
for 10% equity
in my company Dare‐U‐Go!
Being a mom is definitely one
of my biggest accomplishments,
but the reality of maintaining
my busy lifestyle
and work schedule
while raising
two rambunctious little boys
was making me lose my mind.
[ Babbling ]
I needed something
that would help me
quickly feed
my kids healthy meals,
and that is when
the light bulb went off.
♪ Ahhhh ♪
[ Laughter ]
I present to you Dare‐U‐Go!
Dare‐U‐Go! is a kid‐safe,
eco‐friendly bib
with food storage compartments.
Parents can fill
the three compartments
with their kid's favorite foods,
and cleaning is a breeze.
You can literally just throw it
in the dishwasher.
And if the kids don't finish
what they're eating,
you can literally seal it
right back up
and save it for later.
No more waste.
Dare‐U‐Go!, Sharks.
‐Dare‐U‐Go!
‐Wow.
Lisa, you want
to show us the feed bags?
Wow.
You're going right there.
He just attacked!
Right there?
‐Yeah.
‐I don't want to have
to put you in time‐out, so...
[ Laughter ]
Just give me a second.
We like you already.
Oh, I watch this show,
so I know how it goes.
Okay, Robert.
Yes?
Bam!
High five.
Here you go, Robert.
‐Oh, thank you so much.
‐Gosh.
‐Just strap it on, Robert.
‐Thank you.
I got you
some wine and cheese.
‐That is absolutely great.
‐Oh, wow! Listen.
‐I love it.
‐Yeah, it's wine and cheese.
Thanks, Lisa.
Appreciate it.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
There you go, Mark.
Ah, nice and healthy, too.
Dare‐U‐Go!
‐Dare‐U‐Go!
‐Yay!
Yeah.
Daxel, say "bye."
‐Bye!
‐Bye.
‐Aww.
Herjavec: See you guys.
[ Boys giggling ]
Down goes Venice!
[ Laughter ]
Lisa, you must have
a ton of sales
based on your valuation.
D'Amato: Okay.
So, I have been on the market.
We've been selling
for three months.
And I've sold $100,000 worth.
Wow.
O'Leary: Three months?
Yes.
And, also, my brand,
in general, is ‐‐
I come from reality television,
and ‐‐
No?
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
‐What were you on?
‐From what show?
"America's Next Top Model."
I won the "All‐Stars," actually.
‐No kidding.
‐Oh, congratulations.
All right,
so, let's get back to business.
Yes.
What does it cost you
to make each bag?
Per unit, it's $2.68.
All right,
and you sell it for how much?
My suggested MSRP is $22.99.
How much did you do in sales
last month?
About $23,000.
Wholesale ‐‐
Do you have retailers
buying it from you?
There's actually
three distribution companies
that are actually having
a bidding war right now.
‐But ‐‐ But you're saying ‐‐
‐Bidding over what, though?
Just because they want ‐‐
They want exclusivity.
I hustled hard‐core.
I had the patent attorney,
and he did the nationwide,
worldwide search.
Have you been granted
the patent?
Give me one second, Kevin.
‐Good.
‐"One second, Kevin."
Boom.
Design or utility?
I can't see.
This is the design.
I have probably spent
about $250,000 of my own money.
Wow.
The craziest and coolest thing
about this product,
I just need you guys to know,
is obviously,
yes, we have the patents,
but, also, if you see
any other bib on the market,
their price point
is exactly the same as mine,
and it's only one function.
This is four in one.
It's food storage,
it's a plate divider,
it's got the spork in the back,
and it seals airtight.
So, let me just ‐‐
Let me show you guys...
Is there anybody else
doing this?
No. So...
Lisa, can you tell us a little
bit more about your background?
You mentioned you're a model.
What else?
Oh, okay.
I was raised
by a very sick, bulimic mother.
[ Sighs ]
[ Clears throat ]
I didn't want to do that.
Um...
When I was young, I had
developed an eating disorder,
and modeling didn't help.
And I've been a model
my entire life,
so as far as being, like,
a weathered warrior,
I'm definitely that person.
I got through it all,
and I'm now the mom
that I've always ‐‐ I never had,
and I couldn't be more prouder
about it.
Good for you.
Lisa, I have to ask you,
how did you get past your mother
to become a great mother?
[ Voice breaking ]
When I was at the hospital,
and they told me that,
"If you continue on this path,
you won't be able
to have children."
Mm.
And ‐‐
And I just
couldn't have that.
My mom was not going
to define my entire life.
Mm.
There is a tenacity
that I have,
and I am going to break through
any single ‐‐ any obstacle ever.
In fact,
to change the subject...
Let's ‐‐ Yeah, let's ‐‐ Lisa,
let's get back to business...
D'Amato: Yes.
...'cause
it's an interesting story,
and, you know,
you're very compelling...
It's ‐‐ No, no, no.
That underestimates what it is.
‐Yeah, it's a great story.
‐It's not an interesting story.
‐Yeah. That was ‐‐
‐Congratulations.
‐It's a victory. Good for you.
‐Good for you.
‐It's ‐‐ It's a great outcome.
‐Congratulations.
‐But you're here
to get an investor, I think.
‐Yes.
Lisa, how big
do you think it could be?
Good question, Robert!
I'm excited
to answer that question.
[ Chuckles ]
The global baby market
is supposed to reach
$121.5 billion in 2020.
Just the bib industry
within that number is 7.7%.
Got it.
Which equals...
Dare‐U‐Go!
...15 ‐‐ $15 billion.
Mm.
I mean, just the bibs alone
is 7.7% of that ‐‐
that, uh, $121 billion.
That is ‐‐
So your logic is,
"If I enter a big market
and I get $100,000 in sales,
that values my company"?
Okay.
No, you see ‐‐ Okay.
You guys ‐‐
Lisa, Lisa, you lied to us.
You lied to us.
When? When?
When?
You lied to us.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Mark takes issue
with something Lisa said
while pitching her kids'
bib company, Dare‐U‐Go!
D'Amato:
The global baby market
is supposed to reach
$121.5 billion in 2020.
Cuban:
No, you see ‐‐ Okay.
You guys ‐‐
Lisa, Lisa, you lied to us.
You lied to us.
When? When?
When?
You lied to us.
And you don't even know
you did it.
What?
You said
you watched the show.
I do.
One of the things
that we repeat over
and over and over again
is that one of the worst ways
to sell in "Shark Tank"
is to come in and talk
about how big a market is,
and if you only get
one tiny sliver of a percent,
it's a lot of money
for you.
That is a real trap that
all entrepreneurs fall into.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
O'Leary: What you need
is infrastructure behind you.
Luckily, I have that.
So what I'm proposing
is this.
I'll give you $350,000,
but I'm gonna give you
$100,000 for 15%,
and the rest is debt, because
you're gonna need inventory.
That sounds great.
Now you have
to make a decision.
Do you want
to take it or not?
Does anybody want to counter?
Does anybody want to go in?
D‐‐
So, Kevin, I love your deal.
You know, I'm start‐‐
Does anybody want to go in?
I'm not feeling the love.
Listen,
your resilience is fantastic.
My problem is,
is it's very important
when you run a business
that you have a plan.
The creative end is great,
but you have to know
every single detail
in how to run your business,
and because I feel that
you are weaker in that area,
I have to go out.
Okay, I appreciate that.
‐Lisa, just to let you know...
‐Yes.
...the only offer
is from me,
and what's about
to happen now is,
I know that I become
more valuable
every time
you lose another Shark.
So now here's my new offer.
I'm gonna give you
the $350,000.
$100,000 for 20%.
It's up by 5%,
and it's gonna keep
getting worse
every time
a Shark drops out,
and the other $250,000 ‐‐
debt.
Do you want to take it now,
or do you want to have the risk
that the next Shark
gives you another
"Kumbaya" story like that
or makes you an offer?
What do you want to do?
The best thing
I heard from you,
other than
your phenomenal charisma,
is the story
of you growing up,
because if I were
to go through every one
of my top businesses,
every one of them
is headed by an entrepreneur
that came through hell
and back.
Interesting.
‐What ‐‐ What's your offer?
Now I'm gonna tell you
what I don't like about it.
You're all over the place.
And I'm concerned
of you being half
of what a business
needs to grow.
So I think
you need a partner
that gives you
a healthy serving of control.
So I'm gonna make you
your full offer of $350,000,
but I want 50%.
‐[ Whistles ]
‐Ouch.
50%.
30% more than Mr. Wonderful.
Because I think you really need
someone who's a full partner
that's gonna keep you
on track and get you there.
I understand where you're
coming from, Barbara.
I really appreciate your offer.
Mm‐hmm.
‐Lisa.
‐I think ‐‐ I ‐‐
You have two offers,
but I have a news flash.
50% equity.
Now my equity is 25%.
Lisa, while you're thinking,
I love your story.
You're a dynamo,
as Barbara said,
but it's just not for me.
I'm out.
I'm at 30%.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Wow!
‐Okay. Can you ‐‐
‐You better do something.
I'm gonna change my offer,
if I may.
Can you two possibly ‐‐
‐Listen.
‐I‐I would never get into bed
with him.
So, I'm gonna make my offer
for 35%.
$150,000 in cash, however,
and $200,000 in debt.
♪♪
Okay, Barbara.
I'll make a deal with you.
‐You got it.
‐I think that sounds great.
‐Congratulations.
‐I actually structured the deal.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
Thank you so much.
‐Okay.
‐Congratulations.
It's so cute.
I couldn't wear it that way.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
‐Congratulations, Lisa.
‐Okay.
‐Thanks. Thank you, Barbara.
‐Bye‐bye.
‐I can't wait to talk.
‐Pleasure.
So, Barbara,
I'll be sending you an invoice
for deal structure.
♪♪
D'Amato: Barbara believes in me,
and that's fantastic.
A lot of times
when you go through...
[Voice breaking] tremendous
struggle in your life,
you feel very alone.
So when somebody like Barbara
connects with you,
and she ‐‐ She's like,
"I see you,"
it's a ‐‐
It's an amazing feeling.
♪♪